***
So where are you?
You are in some motel room?
You just wake up
and you are in a motel room.
Krass, das ist im Film
extrem realistisch dargestellt.
Mit dem skurrilen Fall von Patient HM
gibt es ein reales Vorbild dafür.
Danke, Dr. Janis, für den Einblick.
Vergesst ihr nicht,
den Kanal zu abonnieren.
Drückt die Glocke.
Dann sehen wir uns bald wieder.
Ich freue mich drauf.
Ciao.
Tag zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Der Einstieg war verwirrend.
Vielleicht
könnt ihr euch nun vorstellen,
wie sich das Leben
von Leonard Shelby anfühlen muss.
Der Protagonist im Film "Memento"
von Mindfuck-Regisseur
Christopher Nolan
hat eine besondere Gedächtnisstörung.
Die wirft ihn ständig
in solche Verwirrungen.
Er vergisst im Minutentakt alles,
was ihm kurz zuvor passiert ist.
If you talk for too long,
I forget how we started.
Next time I see you,
I'm not gonna remember you.
Ich bin selbst vergesslich,
und der Film ist über 20 Jahre alt.
Ich brauche Hilfe
bei der Zusammenfassung.
Die kommt von Wolfgang M. Schmitt
vom Kanal "Filmanalyse".
Man kann sich Leonards Gedächtnis
vorstellen
wie eine springende Schallplatte.
Neue Infos,
Begegnungen und Erlebnisse
kann er sich
nur für wenige Minuten merken.
Dann wird seine Erinnerung
zurückgesetzt auf den Zeitpunkt,
an dem seine Gedächtnisstörung
begonnen hat.
I don't remember.
Das ist unpraktisch.
V.a., weil Leonard eine Mission hat,
die hohe Konzentration erfordert.
Er will
den Mörder seiner Frau finden
und sich an ihm rächen.
In seinem Zustand
ist das durchaus schwierig.
Danke für die Gedächtnisstütze.
Es ist ein spezieller
medizinischer Fall,
den wir hier vor uns haben.
Aber nicht unrealistisch,
im Gegenteil.
Er beruht auf einem echten Fall
aus der Neurowissenschaft.
Den schauen wir uns an.
Leonard erklärt es im Film so:
It's my memory.
Amnesia.
No, different from that:
I have no short-term memory.
I know who I am,
I know all about myself.
But since my injury
I can't make new memories.
Damit liegt er nicht richtig.
Eigentlich
ist das Gegenteil der Fall.
Sein Kurzzeit-Gedächtnis
funktioniert super.
Er kann nur nicht neue Infos
im Langzeit-Gedächtnis abspeichern.
Es gibt ein Problem mit den Begriffen
Kurzzeit- und Langzeit-Gedächtnis.
Auch für Christopher Nolan,
denn es ist so:
Was wir uns länger
als 30 s merken können,
landet schon im Langzeit-Gedächtnis.
Wenn ihr noch wisst,
wer "Memento" zusammengefasst hat,
funktioniert
eurer Langzeit-Gedächtnis gut.
Leonard hätte es schon vergessen.
So nennt man diese Krankheit:
Nolan hat dem Protagonisten
eine Krankheit angedichtet,
die er zwar falsch benannt,
aber korrekt dargestellt hat.
Dafür hat er sich inspirieren lassen
vom echten Fall des "Patienten HM".
Dieser Name taucht in vielen
neurowissenschaftlichen Studien auf.
Er geht zurück auf einen Mann
namens Henry Molaison, HM.
Der litt an anterograder Amnesie.
Er konnte also neue Dinge
nicht abspeichern
im Langzeit-Gedächtnis.
Alles, woran er sich noch erinnerte,
hat, wie bei Leonard,
vor einem traumatischen Ereignis
stattgefunden.
Das hat diese Krankheit ausgelöst.
Bei Leonard
ist das eine Kopfverletzung.
Wir sehen in einer Szene,
wie er mit voller Wucht
gegen den Badspiegel knallt.
Ob das im echten Leben ausreicht,
um diese Krankheit auslösen?
Das habe ich mit jemandem besprochen,
der sich damit auskennt:
Dr. Janis Hülsemann
vom Kanal "Neurologie mit Dr. Janis".
Wenn du die Spiegel-Szene anguckst,
haut das hin?
Schon einigermaßen.
Vielleicht müsste die Kopfverletzung
noch krasser sein
für so eine Gedächtnisstörung.
Entscheidend
für das Langzeit-Gedächtnis
ist der Hippocampus.
Das ist eine Hirnstruktur.
Die haben wir 2-mal,
auf beiden Seiten vom Gehirn.
Wenn bei einer Kopfverletzung
nur 1 von 2 Hippocampi kaputtgeht,
müsste das der andere
einigermaßen ausgleichen können.
Er hätte also links und rechts
Spiegel schlagen müssen.
Ja, irgendwie so.
Bei Henry Molaison
war es ganz anders.
Er hatte keinen Unfall oder Schlag.
Das war eine OP bei ihm.
Genau, bei ihm war das gezielt,
diese Schädigung oder Entfernung
vom Hippocampus.
Das war eine Hirn-OP, ein Eingriff,
der sein Leben verbessern sollte.
Er litt nämlich
an wirklich schwerer Epilepsie.
Mit so schweren Anfällen,
dass es lebensgefährlich wurde.
Deswegen diese Hirn-OP.
In den 50er-Jahren
lief das aber noch mehr so:
Naja, mal gucken, was passiert.
Man kannte vor ihm noch nicht
die Bedeutung vom Hippocampus.
Der Chirurg hat auf beiden Seiten
den Hippocampus rausgeschnitten.
Es hat eigentlich
auch ganz gut funktioniert.
Er hatte danach
kaum noch epileptische Anfälle.
Aber leider
kein Langzeit-Gedächtnis mehr.
Schade, aber das heißt,
dass die Symptome von beiden,
von Leonard und Henry,
schon sehr ähnlich sind?
Ja, das passt super gut.
Das ist im Film sehr gut umgesetzt.
Feine Unterschiede sind,
dass sich Leonard doch öfter mal
bis zu 10 min erinnern kann.
Das war bei Henry
nie länger als 2 min maximal.
Und noch ein Unterschied ist,
dass sich Leonard
noch gut erinnert an die Szene,
die zu seiner Kopfverletzung
geführt hat.
He killed my wife
and took away my memory.
Das ist unwahrscheinlich.
Meist vergisst man auch die Tage
vor dem traumatischen Ereignis.
Z.B. kann sich Henry nicht
an die verhängnisvolle OP erinnern.
Okay, für Henry ist das Ganze
also nicht so optimal verlaufen.
Aber aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht
kann man sagen,
dass wir diesem OP-Fail
einiges zu verdanken haben.
Denn wir wissen jetzt,
wo das Langzeit-Gedächtnis
im Gehirn entsteht.
Ein ärgerlicher Schnitt
für den armen Henry.
Aber ein großer Schritt
für die Menschheit.
Henry ist trotz Hirnschaden
noch ziemlich alt geworden.
Er ist erst im Jahr 2008 gestorben.
Da war er schon über 80.
Und gerade weil er diese OP
in jungen Jahren hatte, mit 27,
konnte man ihn danach
noch jahrzehntelang untersuchen.
Sein Gehirn wurde zu einem
der wichtigsten Forschungsobjekte
der Neurowissenschaft.
Welche Alltagsprobleme
die Krankheit mit sich bringt,
schauen wir uns an.
Um mit einer Gedächtnisstörung
im Alltag klarzukommen,
braucht es ein System,
erklärt Leonard im Film.
Dieses System besteht bei ihm
aus Notizen,
Polaroidfotos und Tattoos,
die er
als Gedächtnishilfe anfertigt.
Doch Notizen
können umgeschrieben werden,
Fotos gestellt sein.
Und selbst Tattoos
schaffen keine sicheren Fakten.
Zusätzlich erschwert
wird Leonards Leben
durch sein toxisches
soziales Umfeld.
Von seiner Gedächtnisstörung
möchten nämlich alle profitieren.
I told my boss about your condition
and he said:
Try and rent him another room.
So how many rooms
am I checked in?
Just 2, so far.
Es ist super anstrengend und nervig,
die ganze Zeit
mit solchen Sachen umgehen zu müssen.
Janis hat mir im Vorgespräch erzählt:
Wenn Leonard nicht die ganze Zeit
an Oldschool-Telefonen hängen würde,
hätte er es heute
sicherlich etwas einfacher,
mit Apps und Smartphone
seinen Alltag zu gestalten.
Aber der Film
ist halt schon älter.
Die Polaroidfotos
und die Notizzettel
sind schon erst mal
eine clevere Idee.
Natalie.
She has also lost someone.
She will help you out of pity.
Henry Molaison z.B. hatte auch
immer einen Zettel bei sich,
auf dem eine wichtige Info stand:
dass sein Vater tot war.
Er ist erst nach Henrys OP gestorben.
Und selbst dieses bedeutsame Ereignis
ist nicht bei Henry hängengeblieben.
Damit er nicht ständig
Leute in die Situation bringt,
ihm diese Info übermitteln zu müssen,
hatte er sie sich
selbst aufgeschrieben.
Bei einem anderen Patienten
hat das nicht funktioniert.
Clive Wearing,
ein britischer Musiker,
lebt noch und leidet auch
an anterograder Amnesie.
Er hat angefangen,
Tagebuch zu schreiben.
Für ihn haben sich
diese Gedächtnis-Sprünge
wie bei Lennard so angefühlt,
als wäre man gerade aufgewacht.
Das hat er auch so
im Tagebuch notiert.
Allerdings hatte er ja 2 min vorher
denselben Eintrag aufgeschrieben.
Er hat ihn gelesen
und durchgestrichen,
weil er dachte: Quatsch,
ich bin doch jetzt erst aufgewacht.
Er hat ihn dann neu aufgeschrieben,
und dann ging das immer so weiter.
Für ihn hat diese Strategie
also nicht funktioniert.
Der Fall zeigt aber ein Problem auf,
das Leonard am Ende ja auch hat:
Nämlich die Frage,
was sind verlässliche Infos?
Und wem kann ich überhaupt trauen?
I'm gonna use you,
and I'm telling you now
because I'm gonna enjoy it
so much more if I know
that you could stop me
if you weren't such a fucking freak.
Leonard irrt ständig durch die Gegend
und trifft immer auf Leute,
die seine Situation ausnutzen,
anstatt ihm zu helfen.
Die Frage ist also:
Wie sicher muss so ein Umfeld
in einer echten Welt sein,
damit sich Patienten
darin gut bewegen können?
Man sollte nicht allein
in der Welt rumrennen.
Man muss schon Menschen
rund um die Uhr um einen haben,
die vertraut sind.
Familienangehörige
oder professionelle Betreuer.
So war das auch
bei Henry und bei Clive.
Das Problem ist:
Jede neue Person,
die man kennenlernt,
und auch die Absichten der Menschen,
die vergisst man ja sofort wieder.
So war da auch bei Henry.
Eine Neurowissenschaftlerin,
weil er so spannend war,
hat ihn jahrzehntelang untersucht.
Und sie wusste am Ende
quasi alles über ihn.
Und er hat sie
jeden Tag neu kennengelernt
und wusste gar nichts über sie.
Irre, wenn du dir das vorstellst.
Sie hätte das,
wenn sie böse Absichten gehabt hätte,
eiskalt ausnutzen können.
Ja, schon, total.
Zum Glück war sie nicht so böse
wie die Menschen im Film.
Aber in ein paar Experimenten
wurde die Manipulierbarkeit
auch ein bisschen untersucht.
Z.B. hat sie ihm einmal
2 Abendessen nacheinander serviert,
um zu gucken,
ob er das 2. auch verdrückt.
Es war klar,
dass er das 1. nicht erinnert.
Aber das Hungergefühl
spielt ja auch eine Rolle.
Das Experiment hat gezeigt,
dass der Hippocampus
auch unser Hungergefühl beeinflusst.
Das hat auch nicht mehr
funktioniert bei Henry.
Schon fies, ihm die 2 aufzudrängen.
Natürlich alles
im Namen der Wissenschaft.
Wir können festhalten,
dass Leonards System zwar hilfreich,
aber keinesfalls wasserdicht ist.
Im Kreis von geliebten Menschen
oder in einer betreuten Einrichtung
wäre er sicher besser aufgehoben
als in der Gesellschaft von Fremden.
V.a, wenn die
Dreck am Stecken haben.
Okay, so what am I doing?
Oh, I am chasing this guy.
No, he is chasing me.
Dass Leonard irgendwie klarkommt,
liegt daran, dass er schon Erfahrung
mit Gedächtnisstörungen hat.
Er hat eine Methode, die ihm hilft,
seine Situation zu verbessern.
Das hängt
mit seiner Vorgeschichte zusammen.
Und mit einem Mann
namens Sammy Jankis.
Leonard Shelby
hat vor seiner Amnesie
als Ermittler
für Versicherungsbetrug gearbeitet.
Sein schwierigster Fall
war Sammy Jankis.
Dieser Mann hatte
eine Gedächtnisstörung entwickelt
und kämpfte
um seinen Versicherungsanspruch.
Leonard musste überprüfen,
ob Sammy ein Simulant ist
oder wirklich eine Krankheit hat.
Die Tests,
die damals mit Sammy gemacht wurden,
helfen Leonard nun auch
bei seiner eigenen Krankheit.
"Remember Sammy Jankis" hat er sich
deshalb auf die Hand tätowiert.
Leonard hat so einen Weg gefunden,
mit der Gedächtnisstörung umzugehen.
Im Film fällt immer wieder
ein bestimmtes Wort: Konditionierung.
Leonard meint damit
das Erlernen von Gewohnheiten.
Also Tätigkeiten oder Abläufe
so oft zu wiederholen,
bis man sie von allein draufhat.
Habit and routine
make my life possible.
Conditioning.
Acting on instinct.
Im Film wird erklärt,
dass dafür ein anderer Gehirn-Teil
zuständig ist als der Hippocampus.
Aber stimmt das?
Haben wir
verschiedene Gedächtnisse,
die für unterschiedliche Arten
von Erinnerung zuständig sind?
Ja, genau, das kann man so sagen.
Es gibt mind. 2 Formen
von Langzeit-Gedächtnis.
Das explizite Langzeit-Gedächtnis
ist für neues Wissen,
neue Erinnerungen an Ereignisse
oder Faktenwissen.
Da ist der Hippocampus entscheidend.
Das implizite Gedächtnis hingegen
ist für neue Bewegungsmuster
oder konditionierte Reaktionen.
Das geht ohne Hippocampus
mit anderen Strukturen.
Also quasi Sachen,
die sich immer wiederholen.
Der typische
Handyschlüssel-Portemonnaie-Check?
Wenn man aus dem Haus geht.
- Genau.
Genau, das hat man verinnerlicht
und wiederholt es jetzt automatisch.
Bei Leonard funktioniert das im Film,
der hat das geschafft.
Der wacht immer auf
in diesen Situationen
und checkt erst mal seine Umgebung.
Die Polaroids sind eine gute Methode,
damit er die Personen wiedererkennt.
Das Tattoo auf der Hand
erinnert ihn immer an Sammy Jankis.
Conditioning didn't work for Sammy,
so he became helpless.
But it works for me.
Wir sehen im Film ja
den Konditionierungstest.
Bei Sammy Jankis,
von dem er das gelernt hat.
Da sind mehrere Gegenstände,
einer davon ist elektrisch geladen.
Sammy fasst immer wieder
auch an diesen Gegenstand.
obwohl er ohne explizites Gedächtnis
auch irgendwann checken müsste,
dass der elektrisch geladen ist.
Ja, und das macht er aber nicht.
- Genau, das klappt nicht.
Leonard sagt deshalb dann,
dass das
eine psychische Ursache haben muss.
Ist das
eine richtige Schlussfolgerung?
Er erkennt richtig, dass es nicht
die körperliche Ursache sein kann.
Er lässt 2 Schlussfolgerungen zu.
Psychisch könnte schon sein.
Wobei man
im echten Leben sagen muss,
dass psychische Gedächtnisstörungen
sich anders präsentieren würden.
Das ist nicht so ganz typisch.
Die wahrscheinlichste Option ist,
dass Sammy doch ein Simulant war.
I never said he was faking it.
Halten wir fest:
Leonards Gedächtnisstörungen gibt es
in dieser extremen Form tatsächlich,
als anterograde Amnesie.
Er könnte mit diesen Notizen,
Fotos und der Konditionierung
tatsächlich
leichter durchs Leben kommen.
Evtl. nicht so leicht wie im Film.
Und wie sein Vorbild Henry Molaison
wäre er die ganze Zeit
auf professionelle Hilfe angewiesen.
und würde wohl nicht zur Mordmaschine
abgerichtet werden können.
*Schuss*
So, jetzt an der richtigen Stelle:
Danke für die Visite, Dr. Janis.
Wenn ihr noch mehr
über das Gehirn rausfinden wollt,
schaut auf seinem Kanal
in der Infobox vorbei.
Da ist auch der Kanal
von Wolfgang M. Schmitt.
Auch an den vielen Dank.
Wenn ihr schon mal da seid,
kommentiert doch mal,
welcher Christopher-Nolan-Film
euer liebster ist.
Vergesst nicht,
den Kanal zu abonnieren,
die Glocke zu drücken,
dann sehen wir uns bald wieder.
Ich freue mich drauf.
Was wollte ich noch ...?
Noch mehr Science-Checks
gibt es auf unserem Kanal.
Hier haben wir
"Findet Nemo" besprochen.
U.a. Dori, die auch
an anterograder Amnesie leidet.
Danach schaut doch mal hier
bei Wolfgang M. Schmitt.
Der hat sich alle Filme
von Christopher Nolan angesehen.
Natürlich auch "Memento".
Copyright MDR 2023